I work with computers and digital video
a lot which means that I think of color
in terms of light in terms of amounts of
red green and blue someone who works
with print might think of color in terms
of combining inks cyan magenta yellow
and black a physicist might think in
terms of the frequencies and wavelengths
of the light but there is a very
different way to look at it to the
chemistry and compounds that make up
colors inside those buildings at Harvard
Art Museum's is the forbs pigment
collection the pigment collection was
put together by Edward Forbes who is the
second director of the museum he'd been
buying works of art and in doing so he
discovered that the dealers in Italy
were seeing American collectors as
something of a mark what he decided is
that if you understand what a work of
art is made of what the original
materials were that an artist used then
you can tell original from restoration
original from fake and so what he did
was start buying pigments to use as
standards for the analysis of works of
art knowing that it was visible to the
public meant that I needed to make some
sense of what we have as a collection so
what I did was take a color wheel open
it out I have yellow in the center and
we go along one way to blue along the
other way to red and purple at each end
so we have unique colors along the top
we have duplicates of those colors which
are chemical duplicates but not actual
color duplicates and then underneath on
the bottom shelf we have the raw
material that makes up the colors above
in effect what we have the materials
that make up paint next to each other
and then if people look at the galleries
below they can actually see what artists
can do with these raw materials if you
think about iron oxide for example
hematite but as it forms in the earth
those slight additions that the earth
adds into the hematite deposits that
allow it to look slightly different so
we have 60 different samples of hematite
each of those is a slightly different
shade from the other these pigments are
not used for restoration we use them
only as standards for analyzing samples
from works of art by analyzing the
materials we can understand
thinking process and if the artist is no
longer alive it's really the closest way
to having an interview with the artist
it's also great for teaching we can show
students how pigments change they not
just fade but some pigments darkens
that's like Vaseline but 80 years old it
doesn't last forever Vermillion red LED
will turn black on exposure to light you
can see how it started and then other
pigments like eosin which van Gogh used
a lot will fade and give an entirely
different impression of what the
painting was to what it looks like now
and so for security we don't have the
public in here some of the pigments are
toxic so we don't want people touching
them playing with them so pigments are
made of mercury they're made of cadmium
arsenic and so on the oldest white
pigment is LED white it's made by taking
lead metal putting it into a container
with vinegar that container is buried in
cow dung so out of manure you get the
most pure beautiful white pigment that's
been around for hundreds and hundreds of
years people use that as makeup lead
white is toxic in the way that lead is
toxic
we have mummy Brown it has been used
probably since the 17th century and it's
made up of Egyptian mummies that have
been ground up into a pigment Indian
yellow is an interesting pigment it's
made by feeding cows mango leaves only
and collecting the urine and drying the
year and what you see on the screen
depends on the limitations of what the
computer screen can depict so videoing
them putting them into the digital
format doesn't replicate the color there
is innovation and people are developing
new ways to depict colors so for example
math Subramanian developed a blue
pigment called Ian's men blue he
discovered it by accident it's very
stable and it's the first inorganic blue
pigment that's been invented for a
couple of hundred years there's been a
new black that's come onto the market
which is vantablack which stands for
vertically arranged nanotube arrays what
you have is a forest of very tiny tubes
and light will go into that it will
bounce around inside the the tubes and
then get issued as he
it's a beautiful velvety looking surface
that doesn't bounce any like back
chemists produce more and more pigments
every year and I think that we're going
to see pigments depicting colors that we
never thought were possible every day
somebody is coming in here taking a
pigment out and using that as a
reference this was beautifully arranged
where I installed it it took me like
four months of lining everything up and
it's all a little higgledy-piggledy now
so you can tell that we use it all the
time it's not an historic artifact it's
something that we rely on to do our work
properly my thanks to everyone at the
Harvard Art Museum's pull down the
description for more about them and more
about the pigment collection
you